قال الامين العام لحال في النيتو ينزل
تمبارج انه لا وجود مؤشرات على ان الرئيس
الروسي الذي مير بوتين يسعى الى السلام
وان هدفه في اخضاع اوكرانيا لم تتغير
واضاف سبتمبرغنا المرحله الحاليه من الحرب
حاسمه ويجب ارسال الاسلحه التي تحقق
لاوكرانيا النصر اعتبر ان الدعم العسكريه
لاوكرانيا اسرع طريق الى السلام داعيا
للاستعداد للصراع طويل يتواصلوا خلاله
دعمه اوكرانيا اضفنا الحلفاء يعلنون عن
مساعده جديده لاوكرانيا في اجتماع
اينشتاين المقبل ومن جانب اخر اعتبر
احتمال روسيا حتى النوويه منخفضا لاسيما
بعد رساله من الصين ودول الاخرى بوجود عدم
استخدام الاسلحه النوويه وبشنه العلاقه مع
الصين قال الامين العام للنيترول الصين
ليست عدوه للحلف لكنها تحدي لامنه وقيامه